on the day that I first worked with
Patrick
he impressed me as
the most prepared
thoughtful helpful wonderful actor I've
ever worked with and one of my dearest
friends Sir Patrick Stewart please
ah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
here we go
look out
all right
nice clip reel nice stuff
you know
it was astonishing I there's never been
anything like that before please nope
Johnny would I lie to you yes yes
yeah but there were things
it's blunt talk talking about orgasms oh
yeah
foreign
I like the stuff from Christmas Carol
but I must say my personal favorite
Christmas Carol and one of my Fondest
Memories ever
is 1991 you were opening on Broadway you
invited my wife the wonderful Genie
Francis and I to go and see opening
night on Broadway Patrick Stewart
one-man Show Christmas Carol he plays 37
characters
right for you who have had the privilege
of seeing it
after the show
we go to Sardis it's like a movie
we go up to the second floor Sardis we
have martinis
and then it about
midnight or one in the morning
someone comes up with the New York Times
which is that time was still a newspaper
that you could hold
you huddle in the corner with the
producers you clearly read the review
the smile on your faces tells us it was
a love letter and it was just like it
was like the movies who watched all this
happen and I was one of my Fondest
Memories of our time ever exactly you're
welcome thank you but what happened
later that night
well um
I was exhausted I mean it was I was
alone on stage for nearly two hours and
I'd given it everything that night and
so I broke away from the party I felt
bad doing that but I just needed to be
in my hotel room
quietly just taking in what had happened
and
um I I as I'm taking my cuddle I find oh
there's a newspaper shoved into my
pocket somebody had given it to me as I
was leaving and uh
I took it out and it was Clive Barnes
who by this time had been the he was
once the New York Times theater number
one and then he moved to the New York
Post
and I read his review and he said I
watched he'd been saying I watched
Patrick Stewart doing this and this was
and then
he disappeared
and I've often wondered what happened to
him
and then tonight I realized
he was rehearsing a Christmas car
and it was one of the loveliest things
that's ever been said to me and
certainly by a theater critic so it was
a memorable night it was a memorable
show
let's go back all the way now
in Yorkshire where I'm told you're from
which it explains doesn't explain any of
your accents to me but that's
speaking of accents do you remember when
you were first hired to sell Pontiacs
and there was a commercial on television
and it was you and you said poltiak an
American car like that
you also remember the night that you
hosted Saturday Night Live
brilliantly
my favorite moment on that evening of
course was when you introduced the
musical guest who was
salt and Peppa
[Applause]
I was out of my day exactly yeah
so in Yorkshire Patrick Stewart this is
one of those stories that he told me
I'll tell a number of these tonight
the back story on this is when we were
Shooting Star Trek the Next Generation
the Paramount there was essentially on
the lot a bar called nicodels which some
of you may or may not remember which was
on Melrose Avenue it was actually part
of the lot not really but they did have
a lot phone to get some of the grips and
Gaffers back onto the stage who came
went there for a month
but when we'd wrap on Friday night at
midnight or one the bar would still be
open and the two humans who are here
with you tonight were the first ones out
of makeup and out of the Wardrobe and
off to the bar
and we had to wait for the Klingon to
get the turtle head off
we had to wait for the Android to get
the gold off
God knows what the women had those
expensive wigs to get rid of
Levar had to take his you know it was
the whole thing anyway Patrick and I
were at the bar first and I would ask
them different things and I said sort of
how I got to know him more and more so
the obituary story is that he was
writing for
the dewsbury reporter
obits tell us what you learned about
that job
about about that job of ready to go
obituaries and having to go to these
yeah
um I I was the most Junior reporter on
the newspaper I left school at 15 my
education was over that was all you got
at the level that I was at which was not
scholarly or academic
and um but strings were pulled I had
been head boy of the school
um boy
yes all right
oh you didn't think it has he said it
it means something different in England
oh
[Applause]
I was a very very Junior reporter
go ahead
and your night
I
um
uh one of the things I learned very
early on I had a boss for the district
that I covered there was a neighborhood
which happened to be where I lived so I
had a number of connections there who
could give me gossip and stuff they'd
heard and how politics were affecting
the community and all of that and it was
explained to me by my local boss that I
would write local obituaries and and I
would go to the given be given the
address of who had died and there was
always a family member a husband or a
wife there and I would knock on the door
and I would say I'm Patrick Stewart the
Jews were industrial reporter
um I I'm so sorry to have heard of your
loss I wonder if I could just ask a few
questions so I would go in and I would
conduct a short interview because the
obituaries were never long
and then um
they would say to me
every time
would you like to come and see him love
he he looks real grand
oh she looks beautiful
and and I would say oh
okay
I will be taken in and there would be a
body lying on a temp sometimes on their
bed still and and we would look at him
and and and uh I would say that that's
that's wonderful well Mike
my condolences and thank you so much and
I would leave well one one morning
I did three of those
and I got back to the office to the
writer's room
and one of the senior writers said to me
Patrick are you all right
you look you look terrible and I said oh
God I mean it's it's these obituaries
and looking at dead body after dead body
and he said oh Lord you don't have to do
that
and I said well what do I do I mean I
don't want to insult or hurt people he
said all right what you say is
oh that's very kind of you but I've
recently lost someone myself ah
a word to the wise it worked yeah
yeah another story I heard of nicodel is
that I loved was about
the Hungarian actor I don't know if it
was part of the district 7 and The Royal
Shakespeare company or the Sheffield
but I think that's enough of a cue to
tell one of my favorites well it is it
was Sheffield and it was uh I spent the
first few years of my career in rep what
was called Repertory Theater which meant
and it started out with weekly rep which
meant we did a new play every Monday
night every Monday night
so we had like three days four days
rehearsal
then I moved on to Sheffield fortnightly
rep two weekly rep every second week we
would do a new play and then three
weekly rep and then finally bristolovic
and monthly rep and then the Royal
Shakespeare company
um where am I going John you're going
with the Hungarian store who tackled you
oh yeah yeah yeah well um
I lost my hair quite early and um
so so when it was really gone I grew it
very long on one side and I would do
this
this elaborate treatment this is my
favorite part you know
and there was
a Hungarian director who was who was
working at Sheffield at the time who had
been at drama school with me he and the
Hungarian actor
um Siobhan elash had both got out of
Hungary when the Russian battles and
fighting started there and they had come
to England to begin to continue their
acting and directing careers and um
one day I went over to George
kishvaldi's house the director and we
were having a very pleasant time and all
of a sudden I felt my hands caught and
pulled me I'd be and I said Jordan what
the hell are you doing
and then his wife walked out of the
kitchen with a pair of scissors
and I knew right away and I said no no
no no no no no no no no and
Jordan was also holding my head and she
cut all this long hair off my head and
I'm yelling no no no no no no and George
gets me and turns me around and looks me
in the face and says no
you be yourself yes
thank you George
[Applause]
also from nicodels
I love the movie June remember June
David Lynch June
[Applause]
particularly the story
about how
he felt and treated you during the
shooting of
it's weird this story yeah uh it's it's
it is a little weird and you want to not
share it or you want to share it oh sure
yeah I I can share it because
hahaha
um I have been set in the script in June
and I'd read it and really liked it and
was excited about it and said yes I'd
love to do something in this
and that was it I never heard anything
more at all again and then I got a job
uh playing a role in a film that was
starring
a Japanese pop singer who was a huge
success in Japan but I I I've never
heard of him and a few of us had and I I
had to go to somewhere in the middle of
England no no it wasn't England it was
France and
um I I was in my hotel room ready to
work makeup costume and everything but
they said look it's going to be longer
than we thought so just make yourself
comfortable and we'll come and get you
and when when we're ready and um then my
phone rang
I answered it and the voice said
Patrick's your agent and I said oh well
what's up and he said do you remember I
sent you that script Dune and I said oh
yeah why he said well you've been
offered one of the important supporting
roles in it I said what and he said the
only thing is
they want you to start on Monday
and I said well
that's not possible because I I you know
I mean you you should know I'm filming
here
you know we're in southern Germany in
the wine country and uh and I I am where
are they shooting
Mexico City okay
he said don't worry I've discussed this
with them your your present job will
take priority over anything in Dune but
when you get a break they will fly you
to Mexico and then you can do some of
your and this is the last for about a
month
and that's exactly what I did so
the time came when I was I had to go the
first time the Sunday I got a plane from
Munich to London where my wife brought
me some extra garments to wear because I
got so little and then I flew to Miami
and from Miami to Mexico City and I got
to my hotel room at about 11 o'clock at
night absolutely exhausted and there was
wardrobe and makeup waiting for me
uh because I was to meet with the
director the next morning and then I
would be on the set the following
morning Monday morning and um so I I I
slept of course badly that night got up
Sunday morning and went to the hotel I
knew the director was staying at and
I've been told this Israel room number
don't go to the desk just go straight up
and knock on the door
well the door was actually open so I
knocked on the door and the voice said
come in
I pushed the door open and there was
recognizable David Lynch sitting at a
chair and he looked up and he said yes
and I said um
uh it's uh it's it's Patrick Stewart Mr
lyncher you're
and he looked at me with his mouth open
and looked at me and looked at me
and then he put his head down and then
he said
all right well uh sit sit down make
yourself comfortable luckily
um he had set up a few minutes later a
meeting with Kyle McLaughlin Jurgen
throck now and Max von Sydow who were
all to be in the first scene I was to
shoot on Monday morning and we were
going to rehearse the scene
and they arrived and when they did they
were so lovely oh welcome Patrick it's
great to see you I'm so glad that you're
here that all three of them were
wonderful guys and Kyle became a
lifelong friend and then um
we went on the set and David Lynch
never spoke to me
and never even looked in my direction
I wasn't there at all now luckily we
were filming in a what was it called the
little one of those little kind of
spaceship things
um can't remember
thank you very much
there's always somebody who knows these
things
and and that it went on like that for a
couple of weeks
and um then one day the producer of the
film
um
Dino DiLaurentis
I didn't have helicopter thank you his
his daughter
uh was producing dude and she said
Patrick um are you doing anything
tonight after we rap and I said no she
said let's have dinner together and she
was a wonderful and lovely woman and I
was delighted
so we went out and we ordered and we had
a glass of wine and then she said look
I know things have been a little awkward
with you and David
but I have decided you need to know why
yeah please and she said well you
probably wouldn't be aware of this but
when you were working in the theater The
Barber come with the Royal Shakespeare
company
David and myself came there to meet with
a young actor who we were thinking about
casting in Carl McLaughlin's role but he
he didn't do it and while we were
waiting for him this man came in in a
long gown down to his legs and long dark
hair sunken cheeks and and really really
shitty looking and David Lynch said
find out who that is get get his name he
looks great and so she did she got and
she said his name is Patrick Stewart he
said great great write it down so we'll
go but the story goes back to uh jorabor
School studios in Mexico and um
there was an actor who had been employed
to play uh Gurney Hallock but uh he had
he had personal problems and he had to
be let go and so that happened this mean
we've already started shooting who are
we going to get and then he said that
guy we saw in London
find his name yeah Patrick Stewart
get him get him he's the one I want
laughs
that's what I'd look like
and into poor David's room walked
and anyway
that's it I like it
I like it a lot
[Applause]
oh
it reminds me of you remember the uh the
series Star Trek the Next Generation
no on on the on the bridge
Sir Patrick would sit in the
Center seat which had
been built for his ass
ergometrically designed am I right so
you'd be comfortable oh yeah on his
right as Wild Bill Riker that's me
bouncing around over here to the left
the beautiful and talented Marina 30s
Council of Troy we're being bombarded by
uh romulans or Borg or whatever the hell
whoever was shooting at us Brendan
malavar down in front of people are
throwing them around in a chair like
this and we're shaking and
and I'm next to Patrick and I hear
during all the rumbling oh Johnny
oh Johnny
25 years in the Royal Shakespeare
company for this
[Applause]
true story
now
I've experienced other shows that you've
been in
one of my personal favorites is the
Scottish play which we saw a reference
to here
did you see Patrick and Macbeth anyone
have for the privilege of this a bam or
on Broadway
and my favorite scene is what is now
known as the
sandwich
scene correct correct there we go that's
all you
oh well it it has always been known as
the murderous scene because it's a
three-hander with Macbeth talking to two
men
whom he is going to employ to kill
Banquo and danko's son when they're out
on the road coming home that night
and it's a long scene and Macbeth talks
and talks and talks and one day in
rehearsal I said to Ruben Rupert Gould
our brilliant director Rupert I I just
wish I had an action to do in this scene
I do nothing I just stand here and I
burn as tiresome and boring but I'm
bored anyway and and he said okay well
um
right uh
why not make a sandwich
and of course there was a road of
Lobster in the rehearsal room a lot of
people sitting around and I said
okay
and he said good and uh stage one get
somebody to go out and buy a loaf of
bread don't cut the loaf of bread we
don't want to come on we want a loaf of
bread and butter and margarine and and
ham and so you can just get it bring it
here so we had a break and then all this
stuff arrived and um
we started the scene
and at one point when I was
feeling I wasn't getting anywhere I went
over and got the loaf of bread and began
and the two murderers looked at one
another
and looked at me and I went on talking
and making things and buttering the
sandwiches and then getting the ham and
some mustard on the top all the time
talking Shakespeare and um and then I
made it I cut it in half and then I cut
one half into quarters and I took the
two quarters and I gave it to the two
murderers
and then I took the half sandwich and
went
yes
and uh we finished the scene and the
room went into Opera people stood up and
applauded and cheered and things
as so did the audiences and it became
known famously now as the sandwich scene
I don't know what
I don't know what Mr Shakespeare would
say
but I have a feeling you would have gone
for it
the value of a good director then eh
no no
yes I was going to I was going to uh
I was going to share with share with you
a couple of my experiences with Patrick
as an actor
when we did the pilot of uh Next
Generation a wonderful director named
Corey Allen
directed us may he rest in peace and he
was very passionate about the work and
he was it was he was the right guy for
us but at one point
I played Commander Riker he played
Captain Captain pecan the wackiest nut
in the galaxy
and we were standing in the window of of
the uh
some part of the ship I don't know what
no 10 forward wasn't there yet oh
maybe the ready rumor anyway we're
looking out the window and beneath the
window is the camera and Corey Allen and
the two of us are and we were just
getting to know each other we were in
those horrible Spandex spacesuits and
and Corey the direction he gave us he
looked up as he was so bad
universe
yeah
for the universe
[Applause]
best Note we've ever been given best
Note
now I went I went on to direct Patrick
in quite a few things actually I have
had spent more time on stage with you as
an actor or as a director than any other
person in my life and I think the same
may be true yeah for you
and it used and I rarely know him
because you know
pretty good actor pretty generally knows
what he's doing I just got to keep him
on track and when I approached Patrick
it used to be he would glibly and
wonderfully say I know I know I know
Johnny act better okay
right and then it developed into
something which I thought was a really
good
very um astute observation of the whole
craft which was I would approach him and
he'd say I know Johnny
think faster
right yeah yeah and it helps yeah
louder faster and funnier yeah
we also did something where Patrick
directed us it was a piece called Every
Good Boy Deserves favor written by Tom
stoppard
music by Andre Previn
Patrick resident Gates was in it the
columnini was in it Brent and I played
the uh
prisoners it took place in a symphony
orchestra because one of the prisoners
imagined that he was a triangle player
we toured who did Orange County in
Minneapolis and anyway it was a
wonderful experience great success
then Patrick started to direct on our
show
occasionally
and one day we were in engineering
he was directing
we all respected he's Patrick stew is he
wasn't Sir Patrick Stewart but he was
Patrick Stewart we knew what we're
getting into and he says to me Johnny
what about this if you come into
engineering and you cross and then
when they're just about halfway across
the room if you would just kneel down
like this first of all there's no
fucking table there's nothing it's me
it's me an engineering there's consoles
here and there I said sure Patrick I I'd
be happy to what am I doing he said I
don't I don't really know what you're
doing but if you could make that work
for me it would be great for the shop
true
fact or fiction
exactly
[Applause]
I think yeah there was a reason oh now
he tells me
so he was coming in here and I wanted to
take the camera down down down down down
so we had him in a lower position with
because of the background that we had
there but I didn't know how to do it
except to ask him would you mind
kneeling time
I did it I don't direct anymore
[Laughter]
I
remember going to see Galaxy Quest you
guys remember Galaxy Quest
which was
so accurate as if they had read our mail
as if they knew us so I called Patrick I
saw it at the at the Cinerama Dome here
Patrick was shooting X-Men in Toronto I
guess yeah yeah so I called back I said
you won't believe this movie Galaxy
Quest you got to go see it so he saw it
twice
and that was uh it has for some reason
it must be awfully encumbered there's
been no sequel done but that bonded us
even more which brings me to X-Men but
can I just tell you when you use you
reminded me of this
we were talking I was remembering that
weekend when I went twice to see the
film it was just overwhelmed by it and
um
so uh Sunny my wife had never seen it so
we watched it three or four days ago
um hold up we watched it again
it's brilliant
everything about it and I know I I you
might have thought I would feel
uncomfortable but but I don't think it
was so much us as worthy examples it was
Bill and Leonard and
they're making fun of them
that's better I never thought that
no I thought the guy I thought that one
of the characters was a had a visor like
Jordy you did yeah he did that's our
show yeah that yeah it was a mix I think
they mixed it a little bit it's okay to
make fun of Shatner
okay
isn't it
thank you very much
anyway X-Men
Star Trek
Picard
Captain Mister Woody Professor Xavier
in
McAllen
who married I went to the wedding of
Patrick Stewart and sunny ozell via
officiating was done by Syrian McKellen
it was the most beautiful wedding great
food great music great people it was on
Lake Tahoe
and then it dawned on a number of us
after a few drinks while we were dancing
we didn't really know what church Syrian
was from but it felt that not only had
Sonny and Patrick been married but maybe
Ian and Patrick had been married at the
same ceremony
which I kind of liked have any of you
had the privilege of seeing remember
when they toured with um with the
Beckett with uh Waiting for Godot and
the Pinter with the no man's land
did it get better than that there was
nothing better than those two
big fans yeah
yeah I'm told we're supposed to talk
about Picard
yes all right very very important very
important and I'm happy to segue into it
we did 178 hours of Star Trek the Next
Generation we did four films together
and then we did three seasons together
of Picard
and
in the beginning of Picard Patrick
called me I was in Maine and he had
called it dinner with the cast to
explain what Picard
was going to be and why you decided to
do it and I'll let you take it from
there
is that a good spot yes yes
it
it it took my breath away
when I was approached
because I was so sure
that with our seven years of series and
four feature films which totaled maybe
12 or 13 years of work on Star Trek the
Next Generation
that we had done and said everything
that there was to say about these
characters and so I agreed to meet with
Akiva goldsman Alex kurtzmann
um Michael chabon
um and
um
and I said but when I got there look
folks I'm meeting with you
even though I am going to turn down your
offer because I respect you all and I
want to explain to you why and they
listened to me absolutely quietly and
attentively
and then there was a silence and I said
so
thank you for hearing me out and uh Alex
kurtzman I remember saying could we just
you know just give you some of our
thoughts about this and he began to talk
and talked and talked and then vital
talked and
uh uh
Akiva Alex Michael all had much to say
and I said well I I'm very impressed
with that but
I'm sorry I I I'm going to have to pass
and
um I got in the car and I was driving
home and by the time I got home
I had changed my mind
and uh
thank you well
I I first of all said to them look would
you mind putting onto paper
as much as you can of what you all said
to me today and they did that
by the way this meeting took place at
the Bel Air Hotel
as fancy as it gets and it's like a
Randy Newman song yeah exactly
and uh
and and I studied what they had said
and I went back to them again and I said
look
I don't think there's anything more that
I can bring and I think it was a Kiva
who said look
more than 20 years have passed
and in that time surely you must have
experienced some change in yourself in
your life in your Ambitions in your
experiences
is that true and I said oh it sure is
yes and he said well
that's what's happened to Jean-Luc as
well but it's more extreme and to every
single one of your cast members
they're not the people we knew when we
were shooting the Next Generation
and I got it
totally and my interests and excitement
was magnified by what they said and I am
so glad that I listened to them and that
I read their notes again because the
three years that we shot Picard was a a
grand experience mostly a grand expense
we did a lot of there was a lot of
negotiating enough a lot of disagreement
um but we the show survived it and by
the time we got to
season three I think the work that Terry
metallist was doing on that seat
and um
I think it says it's as good as anything
that we evident of Next Generation and
uh
it
it's entered into a new world for people
we knew and loved because I love these
characters and I love these guys who
play them all it's very very deeply and
it uh it worked so
I I learned the big lesson there which
was Patrick don't rush into making
decisions but think think think
something through as they had already
thought it through and they persuaded
and convinced me
thank you thank you
we're very grateful
that you uh decided to do it and very
grateful that you decided to do the
third season
to be back on stage with these guys
I I was not prepared because I'd said
early on look I don't want this to be a
reunion show to God not that at all and
you know yeah let's let maybe we should
we should certainly bring Ryka back into
it and good idea
very good choice I did say that but I I
don't want it the whole to be about the
Next Generation
team and uh by season three I was saying
can't we get more of them in them
because I was enjoying the experience so
much and the work that we were doing I
remember one day going in to watch
Marina filming that scene that she had
in the garden in the back Garden before
I shot
that's extraordinary she crushed it it
was it was so exciting to be there
watching you know because seriousness
her dedication her truthfulness was so
impressive and it was like that with
everyone so
we were lucky yeah no we weren't lucky
we weren't lucky
we did the right thing
we made it so here we go
I have some questions from the audience
which I've been encouraged to ask
the first one is my favorite
when Jonathan Frakes is directing you
what if any note from him makes your
eyes roll
question
you don't have an answer for that one do
you I don't yeah cool
what do you think it says about Picard's
philosophy of leadership
that we have looked to him as a mentor
for over three decades this I'm sure you
have a fucking answer to
well
seriously
that is not my responsibility that was
Gene rottenberry
[Applause]
uh Gene and I were never close as a unit
and uh
um a little bit like Port David Lynch
who by the way on our last day of
shooting we all had a wonderful dinner
party and David came and sat beside me
and took my hand and apologized
and we have been in touch since then
we're we're both
meditators and we're involved in the
same kind of meditation and he um
uh well I was going to tell a story
which is so similar to one I've already
told I'm going to move on from it but
Gene and I were not
close and familiar and he uh
nevertheless pitched to me this idea
about leadership and one of the few
things he said to me was have you read
the Horatio Hornblower books and
actually I had as a teenager I'd read
that he said read them that's Jean-Luc
Picard
and it there was so much in those books
that I'd loved and admired as a teenager
that I think I understood it but it got
we got better at it didn't we as it went
well yeah we got better I mean I watched
some of our early scenes and episodes
and
we were very uncomfortable
I blame the spacesuit
I looked like I had a stick up my ass it
was horrible
and Gina Tina said to me Gene had said
to me I auditioned for this part seven
times by the way over six weeks no yeah
and and he said what I really want from
Riker is a
Midwestern Gary Cooper glint never smile
which really feels like me right
so I spent two years trying not to smile
and uh it didn't work out so well and
then things loosened up but by the third
season I think we were we were on a
pretty decent role
all right it says here in this book
what's the hardest or most emotional
episode you filmed during Star Trek
next gen
Inner Light
[Music]
[Applause]
so
you have the flute on your desk
the flute is in my personal belongings
yes somebody somebody sent me the flute
to autograph the box that was in and I
said actually I already have it I own it
not not that one it was a it was a
reproduction of the actual thing itself
um
what else did you steal
I stole my Communicator my Communicator
yeah
um and I asked
if I could have my last uniform and I
was told no that's not
now I knew that already some actors had
taken their costumes with them
next gen now we're on Picard next gen
oh we're on next gen yeah sorry we stole
our uniforms from there because we were
yeah we were afraid to ask
because Mary Howard who's with us
tonight oh yes
would have said you can't have them
Mary
would you mind just standing up for a
moment our producer for many many years
is with us in the house
hi bear bear
there was eighty thousand dollars worth
of Star Trek uniform stolen at one point
is that about right mayor
and
the FBI got involved
and Mary solved the crime
they made a deal the undercover the
crooks who stole the eighty thousand
dollar uniform worth of UniFi Star Trek
shit we're gonna trade it for the kit
car from that Universal show called
Knight Rider
so Legend has it
Mary
and the FBI
have binoculars they're in the desert
two semis pull up one true story or not
mer
pretty true ish
one has the kit car in one has eighty
thousand dollars with the Star Trek
uniforms they swap FBI swoops in
Mary cuff some
Slammer
[Applause]
you didn't know that story
no I didn't know that so
but I believe it and uh it sounds to me
like Mary Howard great producer great
great producer
now this is a question for Patrick
Stewart If Sir Patrick Stewart could
travel to the Future
one time for one week and then returned
to the present day when and where would
he travel to never end a sentence with a
preposition
[Applause]
I I'm going to really disappoint this
question because
the future is unknown and I only want to
know it as it comes about as it happens
what I would love to do
is go back yes and my first choice has
always been the first public performance
of William Shakespeare's Hamlet
it
I want to sit in that theater with maybe
William Shakespeare you know further
down the road and and watched that very
first performance that would be my
moment if I like it but the future
it will happen if you've been to the
Future yeah I've been there I've been
there yeah it's uncomfortable are you
kidding what about the whole thing with
the Borg that didn't go so well no yeah
I don't we don't want to meet the ball
exactly yeah I mean they're out there
there is that
[Music]
speaking of the future
October 5th
I believe is the release date of third
October 3rd
so Patrick Stewart has written his
memoir
making it so
filled with lies
but very entertaining I'm told
please buy his book
he needs the money
you can get an autographed copy if you
pay more
no no no same price same price yeah
that's good to know
thank you all very much for a wonderful
evening
good
success is such a great film thanks for
coming see you next time thank you good
night
[Laughter]